this is a Fox News Alert major
developments out of Washington President
Trump says he will declare a national
emergency in order to build his border
wall you are looking live at the Senate
floor where lawmakers just passed a
budget bill to avoid another partial
government shutdown and now heads to the
house the president says he will sign
the bill and will then declare the
national emergency the White House
describing the plan saying quote
President Trump will sign the government
funding bill and as he has stated before
he will also take other executive action
including a national emergency to ensure
we stopped the national security and
humanitarian crisis at the border the
president is once again delivering on
his promise to build the wall protect
the border and secure our great country
this move obviously comes with a lot of
pushback from Democrats and could set up
a major legal showdown here's Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi if President
Trump decides to go forward with a
disaster declaration they'll be making a
tremendous mistake did I ever say I was
finally a legal challenge I may that's
an option and we'll review our options
but it's important to note that when the
president declares this emergency first
of all it's not an emergency what's
happening at the border it's manatorian
challenge to us the president making an
end run around Congress here he said let
us respect what the committee will do
and then walks away from it well Jesse I
know you pay attention to what I say
right what's up when the shutdown ended
and he said they're gonna do this
compromise bill I said at the end of it
he's still going to declare a national
emergency and remember what I said I
also said I don't know if we're ever
gonna get money for the wall and if you
look at this there's no money for the
wall this thing is packed with so many
poison pills and landmines there's a lot
if you just look at just one right here
it prohibits construction in the Rio
Grande Valley on federal land the entire
Rio Grande Valley is like federal land
you can't build the wall on and it says
what type of wall you can't build what
you can build and the worst part you
have to consult with local elected
officials in the area but
or they sign off on a wall so bado gets
he gets a you know the say on whether
the wall gets built it's total garbage
I don't know how these Republican
negotiators got smoked
but they got smoked hard it's clear that
the Democrats are never going to give
him the wall but you didn't think the
Republicans were gonna go along with
this how could they allow so many poison
bills in this negotiation it's atrocious
Fox News polling says 66% of the
American people want a budget deal with
border wall funding yet there's no
border wall funding in this bill so he's
been sabotaged he has to declare a
national emergency I don't like the idea
of a national emergency but one u.s.
code to 8:08
and u.s. code 284 give him that
authority you know I love because you
flip-flop from day to day to try to make
excuses for Trump yesterday you said
this is not a bad deal 55 until I read
no no no one has ridges Phil Hughes
nobody's read the bill you said
yesterday is not true Jesse it snow at
55 change because I read the bill that's
what happens when you read one you
change your opinion yeah and you scream
let me just say this to me is an outrage
I mean it's this is like a tyrant who
says I'm gonna go around to Congress
forget democracy I'm gonna do what I
want and I'm gonna plea please the far
right wingers on talk radio who
apparently have all the power and half
his ear because guess what he had a deal
in December and he said no to it even
though it was bipartisan endorsed by
Mitch McConnell he now has a deal today
passed by majority of Republicans
endorsed by Mitch McConnell he goes
around the Congress he goes around
Republicans and sets his own agenda in
line with people who are in his ear from
the talk radio show crowd the fact is by
the way CBS poll 66 percent of Americans
say no to a national emergency for this
wall in Fox Fox polling 56% Fox has 50
percent opposed
right now opposed to any wall
construction
two thirds support the deal that was on
the table that includes some money for
additional border security not for a
wall says it right here and so what you
get here is 60% of Democrats 73% of
Republican caucus keep talking I was
gonna ask you about the president now
going into 2020 yes
he's now he could run against
conservatives that the Republicans in
Congress and the Democrats on border
security because they'll say that they
didn't give what the people wanted yeah
look let's dismiss this idea that
declaring a national emergency is a big
deal we do it all the time in fact it's
calling it a national emergency is a bit
overstating it and and I think we have a
bunch of them currently going on right
now so it's not yeah like 30 it's not a
big deal the craziest item the poison
pill that is truly poisonous in this and
this is why he shouldn't sign it is UK
according to the fine print you can't
remove any potential sponsor or a member
of a household who might be a potential
sponsor meaning that's amnesty for
anybody who might be a cartel smuggler
all that brings a minor
yes sponsored if that kid right there he
can just grab the candy turns every
unaccompanied minor into a very
expensive shield you know with it but if
this is why you should hate government
with every fiber of your being this was
a 1200 page bill designed to change yank
the president so you had these months
where you could have listened to experts
you could've actually gone and met and
listened to act yeah wanna keep popping
your head like that but it's true you
know he did the Democrats ignored the
advice does the experts instead they
created a bill just a yank him that's
what you should declare the - emergency
want I listen it's Republicans and
Democrats who voted to pass this bill
which is they will recall Donald Trump
said I have here a tweet November 2014
Obama subverting the Constitution
because he's unable to show you're okay
you're okay with this idea that you
can't remove any potential sponsor
you're okay with that
I didn't rip your own other words you
don't even support what Republicans do
you only support what Trump no no I
think for myself you should you should
what he's talking about those we just
think about the sponsors is the main
point that that's gonna incentivize the
child trafficking which is part of the
humanitarian crisis that Trump and
Republicans are claiming that they want
to solve so I mean look but it's a bad
deal just because Republicans support
something doesn't mean it's a good deal
this is a bet I don't see how he signs
on to this though even if he declares a
national emergency and then he's
acknowledging that yes there is a
humanitarian crisis at the border this
is a big deal we do need more money I am
gonna move federal money around in order
to solve this by signing this he's
saying that he's okay with all of this
stuff and okay with something that
allows for and and foments child
trafficking that prohibits you know
fencing in certain areas that prohibits
certain types of fencing that he's been
out there saying the fencing structures
that we have now don't work this is
saying well yeah the prototypes that you
like we're not gonna go for these so I
don't understand how he how he does this
and has himself on whether it'll got
worse let's go just back to if you're a
are cartel member you're a human
trafficker and you bring a child across
the border
this legislation says they can't deport
you yeah they give amnesty to cartel
members and human traffickers in this
bill or if you're thinking about
sponsoring a minor or if you know a
minor in the United States that you'd
like to sponsor anyone it could pretty
much anybody that has any relationship
with an unaccompanied minor gets a pass
under this bill one even you can't agree
let me just say this Chicken Little has
good here at least today on this show
because you are like the skies flowing
over
the reason that president from sites for
this is oh in this bill I can't move
around the funds that I want to because
remember he was saying well I want to
move additional funds in order to
supplement the limited money coming for
what yesterday Jesse praises the 55
miles given to him by Democrats or I
right now now he's saying oh that's it's
about it's about children or it's about
he's been saying these people or it's
about there's a caravan of invaders yet
remember when we're big problem guy just
lies and they're people who do kids I
wanna guess that wasn't a problem Oh get
out it's true as far as a national
emergency too interesting they're
already shifting the language folks on
the Left Chris Hayes had tweeted out I
mean climate change really is a national
emergency too so now what you're gonna
have is every left-wing activist is
gonna come forward and say well if she's
gonna use this for a national emergency
I'm gonna use that even though we have
existing national emergencies the fact
that Trump makes this contentious issue
a national emergency I promise I'm
declaring that one is a national
emergency all these 30 previous national
emergencies allowed a president to span
unauthorized dollars which is what Trump
did you